so what I thought would be kind of fun
here is to talk about the time in DC's
continuity when Superman got his hands
on a Green Lantern ring now here's the
downside to this video normally it would
be longer but the problem is this story
ends with kal-el sating Krypton but I
couldn't get my hands on the second part
of the story and so I don't know what
happens next and I don't want to lie to
you guys and just make stuff up so we're
gonna go ahead and just just in the
video at the end of this first half of
the story but this story actually comes
in the form of a story called Superman
the last son of Earth and this is
actually an else world story for those
of you guys who are unfamiliar with DC
and Elseworlds
the Elseworlds lineup is similar to
Marvel's what if but where the Marvel's
what-if stories are basically like a
branch of the main continuity this is
say with age of Ultron what if it's a
different take on how things would have
unfolded if a single action had gone a
different way in the age of Ultron with
the DC Elseworlds story these are
self-contained they may or may not have
any connection to the main DC continuity
they usually don't they're completely
isolated self-contained and removed for
the mainstream continuity as a whole and
so what we do or we get in this story is
basically a reversal of the previously
established continuity of Superman
rather than Superman being sent from a
dying Krypton by jor-el
to the planet Earth being adopted by the
Kent's and being named Clark Kent
instead Superman is a native of the
planet Earth named Clark and it's sent
by Jonathan Kent to I guess to Krypton
from the planet Earth when it's revealed
to us that a meteor is going to be
crashing into Earth presumably
destroying it now and the second part I
see we find out what happens with the
planet Earth but again we don't have
that so I'm not gonna tell you either
way whether or not Earth is destroyed
and of course if somebody's read this
story and knows how the second part
turns out for you feel free to post a
comment below and let me know but what
we find here is that when Superman lands
on the planet Krypton he's adopted by
jor-el and his wife now his wife is a
little hesitant to actually adopt kal-el
she really doesn't like the idea of a of
an alien kind of being I guess been
being injected into the lifestyle of the
of the alehouse but the problem here is
that jor-el really seems to develop an
affinity towards or infinity towards
towards kal-el even going far as to name
him kal-el and to effectively adopt
as his son now where Superman develops
his powers on earth due to his exposure
to the Yellow Sun on Krypton he has no
powers and instead he wears a kind of
exoskeleton suit to allow him to
acclimate himself to the gravity of
Krypton but eventually while he's out
excavating as part of his scientific
studies what happens is he stumbles
across a Green Lantern ring now we're
not told who this ring previously
belonged to were somebody just told that
it's there alongside of the lantern
itself and so the result is that when
kal-el picks up the the Green Lantern
ring and the lantern he's told that he's
deemed worthy and so after he recites
the oath of the Green Lantern Corps he
emerges as a member of the Green
Lantern's now while all this was taking
place the planet Krypton was basically
falling apart it was beginning to die
but Superman at the time I guess kal-el
all the time didn't know this and so
what we do is we join kal-el as he
travels back to visit his father but
almost immediately after he arrives he
begins examining his father's computer
files after picking up on the fact that
jor-el seems a little bit put off and
the result is that he realizes that that
Krypton is dying and so what DC seems to
be doing here is that while they don't
exactly tell us why it is Krypton's
dying what's actually taking place they
seem to just kind of be relying on the
previously established continuity in the
sense that there's some sort of nuclear
chain reaction taking place in the core
of Krypton and the result and so the
planet is basically shaking itself apart
and so the result is that with various
earthquakes that are happening here that
are taking place that while the city or
I'm sorry while the planet is basically
shaking itself apart that with the power
of the Green Lantern Corps kal-el
basically takes to space and what he
does here is he begins gathering various
asteroids from around the planet itself
and what we're eventually told here is
that the goal of kal-el is to basically
form these giant pillars or these giant
rods and what he intends to do is to use
the power of the Lantern ring to
basically send these rods down to the
planet and to relieve these kind of
pressure points to basically neutralize
the the nuclear reaction was taking
place in the core of the planet and the
results is that he's successful and so
as a result he's basically saved Krypton
from being destroyed now again this is
where the first half of the story ends
and so if somebody has the second half
of the story if somebody wants to point
me in a direction where I can get the
second half of the story then let me
know but
really able to find it anywhere and so
I'm gonna go ahead and in this video
here I guess we could make stuff up we
could say everybody lived happily ever
after or that Superman went back to
Planet Earth and married Lois Lane I
have no idea that's true or not but the
fact remains that that yeah so we're
gonna bring this video to an end I hope
you guys enjoyed it if you did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
[Music]